bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors david frost a
invoqué un des inquiétudes quant à la
direction que prend actuellement le
gouvernant de boris johnson de quelle
inquiétudes parle-t-il
pas je ne crois pas du tout
personnellement al'excuse qui a été
évoqué le fait que le mini super excitée
partis soi-disant c'est ce qu'il vous
prétexte dans cette lettre à cause des
mesures contre le co by jo on est donc
dans une pandémie depuis à pratiquement
deux heures maintenant il aurait pu il
aurait plus avisés plutôt non le
problème de ces personnes ces coeurs on
sait pas du tout quelle est la politique
tu braques site si vous prenez le cas de
ceux d'en face vous voyez en ce moment
c'est quelqu'un qui a plaidé pour le
rumen pour le fait de rester dans
l'union européenne vous pouvez trouver
avant 2016 des plaidoyers de sa part où
il dit ce serait une catastrophe de
quitter l'union européenne puis tout
d'un coup pour des raisons purement
d'ambitions personnelles il incarne le
break site de plus dur bon je te pose
c'est que ils démissionnent tous
plusieurs ministres excite ont
démissionné vous rappelez-vous naufrage
qui était celui qui a pendant des années
a appelé pour le break site dès lors que
le référendum a été gagnée est ce qui
reste en place pour essayer de militer
pour la réussite est sombre excitant pas
du tout le lendemain et démissionne et
là à quelques semaines de ce qui était
censé être enfin un accord sur l'irlande
du nord même le ministre dupuis excite
s'en va il le fait en plus quand tout le
monde est parti il ya plus d'émissions
politiques à partir de ce week end tous
les députés sont partis pour noël donc
il le fait mais c'est vraiment une
catastrophe pour la politique brick city
bolton pour boston sont de manière
générale
on va parler de boris johnson de manière
générale en défaite électorale fronde
dans son propre conte crise sanitaire
qui prend 2 l'ampleur des scandales
plutôt personnelle avec ce pot de noël
antenne downing street est-ce que c'est
peu de dire que tout va mal en ce moment
pour boris johnson tout va excessivement
mal on ne voit pas du tout comment mes
nuits pour et pourrait se remettre vous
savez c'est vraiment malheureusement
enfin je connais des des qualités à
bruxelles c'est quelqu'un qui sait
gagner des référendums même si même lui
il pousse des causes dans lesquelles ils
ne croyaient pas trop avant c'est
quelqu'un qui sait gagner des élections
à cause de son enthousiasme général il
sait à avoir une vision positive des
choses manque de peau depuis qu'il est
au 10 downing street depuis deux ans il
y à une pandémie c'est vraiment pas le
genre de personne n'en a envie d'avoir
n'a envie d'avoir quelqu'un par exemple
comme un glas merkel un scientifique
en place donc lui a cumulé malheur et en
plus comme c'est quelqu'un qui ne
n'obéit pas aux règles ou cookies qui
établit des règles pour les autres mais
ne les appliquent pas à lui même par le
simple fait des rues britanniques
l'année dernière qui pouvaient même pas
voir leurs proches parce que tout le
monde était en confinement et on apprend
qu'il y avait des soirées et locales au
sein du gouvernement m et le monsieur de
son
secrétaire de cabinet à qui il donne la
charge donc été
cédée mis il ya deux jours de ses
propres fonctions parce que lui même a
aussi tenu des fêtes illégale dans son
bureau c'est vraiment un peu une
catastrophe en termes d'image de marque
en ce moment et tout ça c'est parce que
ces gens là pour des raisons purement
tamby son personnel ont épousé une cause
le break site dans lequel il ne croyais
pas
foncièrement le boys band aussi vous
pouvez trouver des extraits en 2012 où
il disait ce serait une idiotie de
quitter l'union européenne et le marché
unique donc on efface maintenant aux
contradictions que ses mensonges
donne et on voit le résultat
malheureusement avec ce qui se passe
depuis quelques semaines en
grande-bretagne alors on sait que
bruxelles négocié avec londres sur le
cas de l'irlande du nord bruxelles qu
annoncé avoir faire un compromis
peut-être pour penser justement que les
négociations allaient aboutir et puis là
on apprend que david frost finalement à
pas est ce que ça va donner un nouveau
souffle dans ces négociations post
breakes site non parce que le problème
s'il ya un problème depuis cinq ans avec
l'irlande du nord c'est que le problème
n'est pas de solution la grande bretagne
et a quitté l'union européenne et
surtout ce qui est plus important dans
le contexte l'union de veron du nord a
décidé de quitter le marché unique et
l'union douanière de l'union européenne
donc forcément il ya une frontière
quelque part puisqu'il ya eu tellement
de conflits autour de cette frontière
entre la république d'irlande et les
rangs du nord qui appartient toujours au
royaume uni on veut pas qu'ils aient une
frontière pour raviver ces conflits de
jadis mais le problème c'est que les
briquets les briques sitter tout en
clamant haut et fort nous reprendrons le
continent où vous ou le contrôle de nos
frontières refuse d'admettre qu'il faut
qu'il ya une frontière douanière quelque
part donc soit si dans la mer entre la
grande bretagne et toutes vers landes
soit ça sépare les deux irlande les
partisans refusent d'admettre depuis
cinq ans le fait qu'il faut qu'il ya une
frontière quelque part dans ce problème
tant qu' à ce refus de la réalité
restera avec la meilleure volonté du
monde sans solution alex taylor je
rappelle que vous êtes un journaliste
européen merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci pour cet éclairage